foreign
thank you
Council Kevin Proctor um some more it's
my second year on the scripture
um yeah within Coggins and cancer have
been canceled for altering ham and
YouTube screen committee
screen
Rose Thompson labor councilor for
Brooklyn's and I think this is my second
or third year on scrutiny
to Oxford Council for David this is my
second year in school
councilor Dylan but Hale Barnes Ward
Vice chairs
I thank you for those introductions
um just to remind members that we are
being streamed live
tonight
um we'll go straight on to the agenda
and attendances I've had apologies for
councilor Valley Winston
councilor Denise
for any other
apologies of what I've been received
from Council Michael
okay
I do too is the committee membership
and that includes the appointment of the
chair and vice chair we
meet
so that's the noting can we know that
committee terms of reference
again it's worth noting are there any
questions
you know
satisfied with that
we'll move on to item four the minutes
and
these minutes were sent out of late
7th of February
which was a special meeting
to discuss the council council code of
council told
and that was the only item on the object
and the minutes of the 9th of March
ings
an update
um
I don't think that's unanimous haven't
had a chance to read because then it
came out today well I I've managed to
read them but you're absolutely right
there's a point of principle the movie
was four months ago yeah for the minutes
to come out the same day but yeah if one
works one cup
that we absolutely recognize that point
I think there are circumstances around
why they didn't
come until today
and clearly we would try to ensure that
they do go out with the agenda at the
right time in future
hello
hi can you introduce yourself
um we have started the meeting
is always quite a big traffic yeah no
it's no problem I just want to make sure
we know who's who uh and Dave act and I
share these
people think we have had introductions
okay okay well welcome to the committee
thank you thank you
we're now on
um Titans
five Declarations of Interest
versions of Interest
no
okay
move on now to a question from the
public which I don't have any
um
item seven
continue to review implementation called
and for those members that don't know
and the
scrutiny committee have set up a panel
to review
all aspects of scrutiny
to see where we could improve on our
scrutiny
um it was quite a big piece of work
um for the report
outlined that
in the papers
there's a
um
several recommendations
and I think to be fair we
um you know we will be trying to
um Carry as many of those
recommendations
but I think it is an involving
um
a set of recommendations
a few problems in terms of timing for
the first part of the recommendations
which
um was recommending that
that
members
particularly the chair and vice chair
moved with the leader of the council and
the executive members to see what their
key
decisions would likely to be for the
coming year and to see whether we
um you know who we should be
trying to work with the executive to
improve decision making and and so on
unfortunately that it did happen but not
fully and that was because of the
pressures of time basically
um and we
we realized that
um from the AGM
but where the committee is actually
appointed that we couldn't do anything
before that
um
and
between that period of the AGM and this
first meeting it was impossible to get
meetings sorted out with like all of the
executive numbers of
we
um have passed the leader of the council
and I think we've got a date now for
July that myself
will
meet with the building
um
we probably will need to meet with some
of the other executive numbers but I
think
in future we need to to try to arrange
our timetable in terms of the meetings
uh the first meeting should be in
probably the middle of July which would
give us
a couple of weeks to do that part
um so I apologize for that
but that was a reality
so any questions or points if anybody
wants to
make around the recommendations
yes those
I just wondered whether because you've
got so many new members to scrutiny it's
quite quite a
cared around what should be scrutinizing
what we shouldn't be scrutinizing
whether we could get some training in
just before the first meeting that's at
all possible yeah I mean I think that
that was
quite a big part I think of the
recommendations and the important part
of the recommendations to essay and
um it's not been possible to do it as
yet but I think it's something that
we've really got
um you know
a commitment to do
and I think
through through this year I think we're
going to try to organize
some training and
I don't know John do you know
oh yes chat I mean absolutely we will do
we did members induction
um it's all gone now I think
um but the idea from the this piece of
work was to get some substantial
training for members and one of the
things we said we would do is over the
course of this Municipal year is put
together some substantial training for
members but we would base around the
screw the toolkit that we promised we
would write and have ready for it for
this time next year which we are still
on track to do that and we can always
offer some one-to-one training to
members especially to new members if
they wish to understand screwing in more
detail that's absolutely not a problem
uh we can do that and I think as as
counselor actor has mentioned we were a
little bit of a victim of our own
success we hit Council and we wanted to
hit Council but it came in a little hard
and the problem with that was the
committed timetable already produced my
team was gearing up for the election by
that point and we just couldn't roll
everything out which we thought we could
but ultimately we couldn't so for next
year we've learned that let's just push
the Committees back a couple of weeks
and it gives us some more time and we
can certainly then plan the meetings
without the leader and the other exec
members in between or suddenlach take
this slot and then that would nice to
feed into to the community cycle as we
move forward but in terms of the
training yes we will we've been looking
at some best practice already there's
some good stuff out there but we have
some good stuff by ourselves that we're
happy to roll out now if members wish to
receive it
yeah I'd like to express my
disappointment that that meeting didn't
happen I know it was through nobody's
fault but I would just like to express
that because the scrutiny review was a
really exciting thing I think to be
involved in and it felt would be really
Progressive and changing things and
being able to be far more proactive and
do pre-decision scrutiny
um and I think it's a real shame that
that hasn't happened but my question was
really about it it does mention
especially in the cfgs report about
having more dedicated Office of Support
and I'm aware that one of the scrutiny
officers did leave I forgot my name
sorry yeah once it's any indication of
being able to replace her
through YouTube yes he starts on Monday
funnily enough
um we have struggled for a resource
we've not I've been here two and a half
years I've not been fully resourced
since I've been here and the time where
we would have organized a lot of this we
were actually down three members of
staff at that point so we've slowly got
ourselves back up to full speed
um yes it is disappointing we've not
been able to do some of the get some of
the meetings in place that we wanted to
but we do have the pre-decision scrutiny
lined up there are some things on on the
next item in terms of additional
resources
um that's not for me to say obviously
that report has gone through Council and
was improved by Council that we are
doing something called the framework for
change what we are looking at the
resources of the governance team because
I don't cover just this heck of
Elections and school appeals in the
Civic so we have been reviewing that
over the last 12 months or so and that
should hopefully
um produce something by the end of this
year so
um we are back up to full strength in
terms of the governance team at the
minute so Fabiola has been replaced what
I'm also doing is
um there'll be one officer per committee
so Fabiola doubled up we won't do that
anymore we will get one dedicated
officer per committee it's not as much
as I'd like to give scrutiny but it's a
step forward and then we'll try and take
a bit more
thank you it was just a quick point to
make as well about the the report there
were some really Illuminating findings
in that in terms of how things could uh
progress
and reflecting on the fact that you know
that the important outcomes were that
the project aimed should be looking at
the aims and priorities of what the
council are and those things that really
will benefit the community with a wider
Community which people are interested in
a lot of people
foreign
a group of hosts for spiritually
and one of the things that isn't on
there that we might have a question of
that is okay
the substance support
is being closely recognized is not
something that is within the council as
Authority so Magnum is about the
resident but the council can't change it
can't do it and
that might be a reason to answer the
projection
s
yeah I've just got a question about how
the different solution committees would
be working together and we communication
between them because it might be that
what we do can enhance what they're
doing and I feel like more collaboration
would be really useful
thank you
you've got the fun to do it yeah
I'm sorry
um yeah the the other thing that was in
the review was a report from scrutiny to
the executive and Council
um so you know all of that will begin
that jump
yes chair I mean the
um annual review has already been
putting the committee calendar so we did
manage to get that on the draft
community calendar Council in March and
then obviously he agreed it in April
annual Council so that is in the dates
there it's in March that's the best I
can remember it's early March annual
annual review through the it is in and
that is something we will we will do
each year now the purpose behind it as
in the report is you don't need a big
review like this to happen every so
often it's incremental changes to
scrutiny to catch up with the latest
trends or stop practices that don't work
anymore and pick up the new new best
practice so um that will happen
um and then this counselor said the
reports to the executive into Council
will obviously confirm this committee as
well
okay
uh thank you chair yeah I see the
process uh one of the Key activities for
this committee is to review the budget
at the Christmas New Year time
for as you can see many of us maybe not
have that's such a strong financial
background I think this is quite a
special review especially so so my my
idea so my question is if we can have
more specific training for the people
who don't have Financial background and
how we can follow the process follow the
way to have a problem especially on this
project yeah I mean I think
um it's a good example really around
training needs so I I think we can
actually organize that within our own
departments obviously
looking at John yes we can and we will
we do try and do that each year anyway
one of the points from the review as
well was budget scrutiny it's a bit of a
difficult topic for scrutiny nationally
anyway because it's very hard to
scrutinize the budget because the budget
is so large many councils focus on
service reduction of service growth if
that's being proposed and what we do
here is over two weeks over two meetings
we have the full budget members through
the review felt that didn't necessarily
work as well as they would like because
the problem we Face by doing it late
November early December is the budget
still fluctuating nearly into the
February when they Shore it up and
they'll go storms eckington Council so
we did agree through this process that
we would look at how we did budget
scrutiny it's something Alex and I are
going to pick up without who for the
providers in this report because they
said they had a couple of authorities
that were doing something new I think
the format that we have is very good
support it I think at the minute
um knocking words in member's mouth but
what's through the review was it was too
much information
formation changed subsequently so um but
this is scrutiny's opportunity to
influence the budget and influence the
executive so we do need to do it but
um yes I agree we need to look at what
information we put in front of members
and then how we support members with
that information our finance team is
really good Graham Bentley our director
he's very supportive of members and very
positive of scrutiny so it won't be a
problem what we ask when we do ask about
it but we do need to I think we said we
would do around September time that we
would look at well what information do
we really want to put to scrutinize
budget place sorry one last thing we
also said through this and through a
previous review that report by exception
would come to this committee so if
anything financially happened that was
unusual or not expected the report was
industry
yes thank you uh on the subject of the
budgets company uh I think the members
might want to understand why you know
that you've got the accounts and audit
committee which is effectively a
scrutiny committee looking at the budget
uh with more dedicated members and how
that fits in with uh budget scrutiny
from this committee that you know what
makes the difference
that's right
um clearly we do have the account
and
I think when we come on to the
um
whether we have
two three monthly report about
uh
okay
I think jupitation
foreign
community
right are you okay yeah
okay now it's working thank you uh I'm
so
I think Trafford has already declared we
have a common crisis
and and also it is written into try for
values in current progress we haven't
seen any
progress report on this topic and I
wonder if Council should have kind of
progress report about how we deal with
planning prices if they are maybe the
school exclusive committee can't
consider to look at the programs well
should we finish off the this item
around the scrutiny review and then move
on to
um
for the next year
okay
everybody okay with that right
thanks for that description on the video
um item 8 is the scrutiny committee work
program
um there was
there is a report on that which you've
all
received
um
with
items that were
ongoing from previous years and
suggestions for this year I know that
um
you Council for grass has
went into
myself yesterday
to to put forward
for recommendations to scrutinize and
we'll come on to that I think the best
way to deal with this is to work through
the papers that we have
so
um
right
so
before submission
from
the work program Manchester Airport yeah
sorry okay sorry we both said okay so
mine was just about the actual layout of
the report it's the um gypsyramid travel
report seems to be so it got a sub item
of item eight
um or is that I was wondering if that
was a typo which is
well yes
and the report was uh it's only just
been to the executive
for earlier this week
in order to
be okay to it was a bit late for
a full response officers to attend an
executive to attend so it was more on
there because within that report there's
a number of responses to an actions that
they were going to do over the year so
um in the access that they're going to
bring
a review of whether
most negotiated stopping
where what
else do you control
yeah
just quickly this is a report of
recommendations I've gone to the
executive last Monday as we put in the
previous report the screening review
automatically now you will get an update
report six months within six months with
a detailed response from the executive
whether they've accepted the
recommendations or not an opposite value
with more detail at that point
yeah I think in choosing
topics you've got to be mindful of
traffic
and
I think that
I've seen somewhere and I can't find it
now there's a scoring
points
on what the important topics are
page
153.153 is the summary table
foreign
could you just talk us through
how are we going to
decide because as you've just right and
point out we will have a financial
capacity so until we've considered all
of the possibilities on the table
you can't dress the first one because
the first one might not make the cup
when we decide on capacity so and over
some stuff in here
there's some stuff that people purchased
an email to you I know that I've
remembered got some things to add so can
you just talk us through
how we're going to
get up make all of those visible
before and identify what's likely to
fill our capacity
before we judge individuals
yeah
I think it's difficult because obviously
I'm not sure
um this meeting is more to put forward
all um the ideas that you have and then
for visibility it'll be done like once
we have a list of them all we'll
circulate with everyone and then have
like an informal meeting where you will
and go through those and then slot them
into the work program over the course of
the year so this one's more of a
brainstorming kind of uh first meeting
does that mean that after this formal
meeting before the next former meeting
we'll have an informal meeting to decide
what the agenda for the rest of the year
is I kind of thought we were doing that
today
well
well I thought we were doing it today
but
um
I mean if if we went through the paper
the the actual
topics
so we'll give it a start wouldn't it to
to go through that Jill
um
that's a really good idea that we have
time to actually
think carefully before we choose them
but I just wonder what the time scale
would be because I'm aware that it's
already
you know the next meeting is September
isn't it and
so it's one too many come on at once
um so uh the time scale will be
um get all these uh suggestions in today
uh probably circulate the list of them
um
by the end of this week or early next
week I also circulate again that um
selection criteria and to have a refresh
in your mind and then please look to get
the informal meeting
um
or probably the week after the next and
because it'll just be a virtual meeting
and to have a full discussion get those
out and then because we'd also probably
have other info meetings before
electronic if you want to do task and
finish group to get those get started
before the next full performance so it's
all about that there'd also be
um discussions around
like it's not talking about sharing
information and all those you know it's
like the implementation of new
technologies and ways of working that
we're going to be doing to get those uh
to get enrolled
so can I just ask one more question
about the task and finish groups is
there any kind of limit to how many we
can have on that as long as there's
office is willing to take part in them I
think he does
except for me anyway I I think that's
for us to decide
and I think that work can be done as
soon as we've gone through care
um you know selective of pre-writing
could be touching things
and then
you know that those groups would be able
to
almost set up themselves
the health food
so terrible
I think I mean this may be something
about this year maybe a result of the
issue we talked about earlier but it
seems like we're having a formal meeting
to throw in ideas and then an informal
meeting to make decisions
but but it's probably too late for that
it's probably right you guys have been
busy but in terms of maybe next year the
informal meeting for the income of their
end is
decision making out formal meeting seems
like the way to go
thank you
kind of kind of still in half it's under
that um just from an immature point of
view can we not call whatever the next
meeting is an informal meeting because
it's probably the most important meeting
that we're going to have as a committee
this year yeah and if you're talking
about the week after next I think in
other currency that's the week before
the schools break up so I suspect people
are going to be pretty busy so if that
date has not already been proposed could
we kind of propose that possibly today
because otherwise we aren't going to be
there yeah I mean I I think we can
because we can call a meeting when we
want but you know people always
depending on obviously
to do that
so I think rather than call it
okay
a meeting
um no you can't
say if you wanted to call it full
meaning of this committee would have to
be in this chamber and we would have to
follow all access to information there's
a reason why Alex took the word informal
is we can call it tomorrow if we wanted
to we won't have to publish an agenda we
don't have to make it available to the
public
yeah if if it was a continuation of this
ATM
with that milk covered
and I think it would bro
I think they're in a gray area there
again just in terms of the proper way of
doing it making it
experience in public is part of how we
want the decisions to be made so we
don't want to find a quick way to make a
decision that's not transparent unless
we don't have publish minutes of and we
don't have to put on YouTube we actually
want to make the decision doing their in
the appropriate way that way
my friend
yeah but that would only be an informal
meeting where you can't make decisions
I think uh we're getting slightly
hundred Palm on making decisions it's
about selecting your work program and we
can certainly publicize what we've done
and what what topics have been created
on the on the website
um after this meeting so we'll do this
meeting is on our website we can then
put up an update and that the outcoming
items were automatically chosen by
members
um I agree with you that we don't want
to be seen to be doing things behind
closed doors which is obviously the
opposite of what screen is meant to be
but the idea tonight was to try and save
us some time was to have that discussion
open in the public and then you drill
down at the topics you want to choose so
nothing new would be added at that
future meeting it would just be a
finalization of the topics that you
wanted to do within the resources that
if that was achievable if you're not
comfortable with this idea then we can
look to try and put something a formal
meeting of this Committee in
um
back end of July then it would have to
be for us to meet all of the relevant
criteria
I think the
thing that we could
top it because we might
you know we might actually come to an
agreement of what we actually want to do
rather than discussing you know
where you know hits and reports
so
I agree Jack is it possible to crack on
we might be able to get this for this
meeting and the information proposed on
in this meeting exactly but it would
help if we had a massive whiteboard
where the things that were yeah well
let's just try and go through
my area
that's where the time
so should we start with Manchester
Airport
now this was an approach from that
to a good chips
good to me so we put it on the paper
with Manchester Massachusetts
the next stage of the investment exam
and other related history
no
you know
I don't know whether
you know that is a priority
so it's something that we have been
asked if we wish to do it but we don't
have to do it
outside
forgive my ignorance if this is um not
the topic but it is it
um related to the amount of investment
that we receive from the airport is that
part of that object obviously that's
hugely important for the council and we
did I heard something about that
recently from one of my introductions
and
there's the investment that we get from
them and also interest on loans and
things and that may be why it might be
particularly important rather than just
something to know I don't know yeah
we don't know always
I think the dividend
um you know
I don't think it's it's up for scrutiny
to decide you know whether we wanted to
discuss that or not
yeah Kevin
yeah in terms of you know the things
that we're looking at I think I would
put this down is quite a low priority we
don't really know and I don't think
we're gonna have much
ability to change anything that's what I
think yeah because
um you know our impact on that is going
to be very very low so in terms of what
I'm not saying I do it but I think it
would be a lower priority in terms of
anything else that's coming forward for
me anyway I mean what we could ask for
report
and then you know take it from there
then
I I think at this moment in time it's a
low five
yeah yeah I agree I mean I don't think
it's got any up has any value to what
we're doing really but I think there is
certainly a place to look at our
dependence on the airport in especially
in terms of climate change and things
like the coronavirus and you know the
impact of the impact of us relying on
that but that's another issue isn't it
and I don't know that it's a priority at
the moment because there's so many
others
foreign
and I wonder if for the the meeting we
can have a sketch a little report as to
what this is actually about and as to
whether it's more appropriate to go to
accounts in order for to us or um if
it's about some very specific detail
or some bigger picture issues um as
filament
yeah I think uh
considering many of our residents in
this area are actually using the airport
until you last a few weeks so their
travel their life has been hugely impact
due to airports disruption and all all
recipes I think they are have
well if we can work with them in the
right way we can certainly bring more
benefit
affecting other our residents and in
terms of the the connection to this
topic I think maybe if you if you are
using the scoring guide maybe I would
say two they've got some some
connections however the current topic is
very very weak they probably need more
clarity however they may give us some
opportunity to Define what kind of
topics we are going to discuss with yeah
I think if you using the current scoring
cards I would say we probably have the
um yeah six to seven ish and uh we
should have opportunity to to carry on
this topic
yeah I mean I think
I think it is
if we had more information
then we could consider consider it in
the return
yes
correct me wrong if someone knows that
the absolute I think attractive council
is the three percent shareholder in the
airport so that might impact our
thoughts on what we want to scrutinize
other executive are doing opposition it
was something that we are three percent
stakeholdering
I agree I I think it's low priority
course and we wouldn't have any
influence on our shareholdings and the
Investments we get from from the airport
um so and I'm just wondering how do we
do we vote on whether this goes on to
the onto the work program or do we apply
it
priority
yeah yeah sure yeah I would just I
generally agree with that as well but
the the thing is there's been pointed
out it is a big concern for residents
the way things have been there would be
a point of interest but the fact is we
haven't really got the information to go
on
and it it's not something you can make a
decision I don't think
[Music]
see the members decision and he probably
does look like a low priority you could
make an argument to have it on its local
Improvement that probably suggesting
improvements for local area to keep you
through a public you could question
whether it's for performing service and
high level of dissatisfaction which is a
look at the news in a minute
um I I appreciate there is very limited
information that they approached us with
that information this does happen from
time to time from stakeholders or key
third party
um partners that we work with looking to
present something to members the key
thing behind it is is do you think you
can have influence I mean you could ask
them for a presentation at your next
meeting and give them 20-30 minutes of
your time and then see if there is
something that you want to scrutinize
but as I said if it is members low
priority then obviously treat it as such
I just think we need to be really really
clear and accurate this isn't asking to
do onto scrutinize the operational
failings of the airport this is that's
going to want to scrutinize future
investment plans the thing that the
public are concerned about isn't what
the future investment that gets into
that and the bank's going to get lost
we're going to get the blame and that's
not what's being proposed here so that
isn't relevant tackling
I think it would be interesting to know
whether the all the other councils have
been approached as well because they're
all a similar State sharing so whether
they're just trying to get feedback from
all the councils as to what how they
feel about it it may be something
they oh now it's working so what it is
is that they have delivered
um an update to Manchester Council I
think it was um after a meeting that
Bridge Road came across uh that
presentation and they also offered it to
him at the same time so that's where to
come from they are doing around
the other vessels authorities
um
thank you
and yeah I think it's really important
that we do discuss this I mean Building
New Roads is pretty much directly
contrary to the council's priority of
tackling climate change so if we are
going to do things like that we need to
make sure that we are absolutely
scrutinizing them that we're getting
loads of information there was a huge
amount of concern um around Carrington
and Partington around this issue and I
think
um the more discussions we have the more
detail we get into the more we hear give
residency opportunity to come and raise
issues and and bring questions and
listen to the debate and contribute I
think is really important
thank you this has come to scrutiny
before we had a report about it
um and although we can't change anything
about the the road itself we did come to
the conclusion that we weren't too happy
with the consultation that had gone gone
on before it so we did ask if we could
be involved in the next part of the
consultation just to to make sure we
were happy happy with that so I would
like to focus on the consultation
yeah and my other concern was the
financial risks as well because I know
another Council just recently canceled
the Vogue building because of the
financial indication so I would still
like to you know keep scrutinizing the
cost of this as well
[Music]
thank you uh yes I was just gonna say
yeah the last meeting I think they said
that the next round of um consultation
will be starting around uh October time
and so I will go with them and go back
to them and find out if they've got
solid timings for that and have that
information but when you have the
full-time mean so you can schedule it if
I can
yeah I think that would be uh good to be
involved in the next stages of
consultation obviously because the I
think when the Aboriginal discussion
there was concerned about uh the peat
bogs and stuff that's underlying the
existing Factor what the expense of it
was sort of those sort of things that
need people just need reassuring as to
what the uh the situation is that might
come up
yeah
finally just if this is to go on future
genders again I really object to the
phrasing relief road we know that I'm
building new roads actually induces
traffic demands and does not give relief
from congestion problems so um as I've
said before um the new road across
Carrington mass will be a more accurate
description if we could use that
foreign
the next items of the budget
presentation
which we have touched upon
we will be holding two
like sessions
that have a
we will also have
to say September of October October
the reputation
so I think they're pretty
straightforward is obviously
being organized for
so things can change even though
I think that's pretty straightforward
standards
yes
it's just a comic
and I know we do this every year but I'd
like a big emphasis on all the
councilors taking part in budget
scrutiny because we've all got ownership
everything it doesn't matter what group
we belong to you know it's a tough
budget we've got to deal with and I
really do think all Council need to get
involved in that scrutiny process
down to this committee to do that so I
just think that we emphasize that all
members will tell you right and come to
the training that we're looking to
provide as well yeah I mean I think we
we have opted
um
right should we
head on to the other page
ongoing test and finish work
the Highway Maintenance
are we
still wanting to do that I know that we
struggled with this last last year we
couldn't get
killed
and yeah it just didn't get started last
year
um I I'm not quite sure about it because
I think it's a big one and I know
there's also been an Amy review recently
so
feel like
I'm not sure I was I didn't feel as if I
approached it or there is a high
priority of it it really is but it's
again about what we can influence
I'll be coming on the opportunity to
talk about the early seven year review
is it a chance to just fold it into that
well
this was
specifically about classical things
just make a point about this
good times anyway
I just want to say it it seems to be
very strict guidelines on things like
options
whether I mean unless you're going to
try and change the
priorities or how to accept the criteria
for these things
how you can influence it is going to be
difficult to say oh yeah it's going to
be Mystique
quickly
yeah just looking at the pressure of the
choosing things and I mean obviously
this is something that would really
affects a huge number of people and it's
a huge area of interest for residents I
know in my in my area I'm sure
everywhere else so it seems very high on
on that criteria in terms of what we can
change and what we can impact that's
really where the question is I wonder is
this task been finished with the correct
so it is down not a scrutiny topic but
as a task and finish group so I suppose
one question is is that the correct
um
way of dressing we don't have to say oh
we're doing a test finish group what
we're doing nothing we could put it down
as much as one of the future meeting and
the attack of his group could come from
that if we felt there was something that
we do
yeah we've got training tomorrow haven't
we online Training Club
for about three hours
you know I've signed up to it if anybody
else has
I'm just thinking out at the back of
that
there's a few people attending I would
imagine
it would be a bit more interesting I'm
seeing that a bit a bit more knowledge
about the issue
of agreement councilor cognitis it's an
important issue for all residents
foreign
just try to build on this one I think we
have a high inflation at the moment and
also material costs going high labor
costs going on I think many people's
assumption is if the budget if the
budget doesn't change
this New Year's Highway program have a
significant reduced during their their
work and look around if you say lastly
they kind of repair 10th streets this
time if you only say three or four I
think we for that reason we probably we
spend more time to look at how they fit
all those programs how they do how their
future Works they can help them to
yeah at least make to make sure that
they start money more effectively
foreign
thank you
so this that's just that this might be a
good idea to get yourself more
information specially if you know
there's already been a review then you
can look at the outcomes of that review
it's findings and then you might want to
say well it's not going far enough we
might be perfectly happy but that's a
good use of your time if you wish to do
that yeah
just in addition to that just given how
um
larger topic is
I didn't go into it maybe
for half
two hours
as well depending
off those definitely making worth having
it
yeah I I suggest that we do that we
with reaction to give us some more
information on what we're trying to do
today
okay
um disability access
um
it was an intern report
relationships
a series of recommendations
foreign
shows up for financial further but yeah
whether I missed this because
that's their suits
them now we've got a report to come
because behind the scenes we've been
pushing on it because
um
what
could we call was recommending
through the planning process
that
disability access into building
should be a priority that was being
resisted at first other planets
well I do know why
the previous request
those funds have been Rewritten
foreign
control
Valley was here
I have the um response from the
executive is going to the executive at
their meeting in July and so that will
probably
and so um that can come to the committee
of the next
as well what type of
foreign
the next one is Travelers
um work on going following ancient
reports in March we did
do that before it did go to the exactly
um
we've had a a response from the
um
I think is it in this
yeah in the before and and
um
it was
had presented it to the executive and
they were quite supported with our
recommendations but who are some
outstanding things that they wanted more
time
to consider the viability
and so on and they will what they've
said thought that they would be further
report
the big end of this year
I think
at that point thing I want to do
so for the moment
we will leave
the further consideration
and other spots
from that deliberations
okay
um the next one is
um cost of place in all parts into field
of trust
this came from the full Council a
decision of the Court Council
where this was the polls
and
um
the council
agreed that
whom they would put this to exclusively
committee to see
and ask them to do a piece of work on
this um this topic
so
you know we could consider this for a
testing industry
um
yeah uh Liverpool Council have done this
already and so there is some good
practice already being done so I think
it would be good to have a talk
but
um
thanks I think
there's a word missing or it's Miss
phrases I think review the costs and
particularly of things that doesn't make
sense I presume that means review the
costs and also the sense of the original
idea is a sensible idea yeah what it
said was I think particularly
yeah they view the costs
um the viability of clothing you're all
outcome
if we were going to make this activist
groups now I'd want the start of that to
be is it a good idea and if it's a good
idea obviously question is it affordable
or not we're going to do it unless it
costs too much because I think we're
here
it's a good idea and
is this a good idea and then if it's a
good idea is it affordable
yeah and I think that's about ended up
with it being resolved but it would be
scrutinized so I'm often say and I don't
think if that's the case I don't think
this is a test and finish because that's
kind of fun we're going to do this well
yeah I mean we should scrutinize is this
a good idea and I'm saying
what what we need is
some information really I don't know
anything about this
and it's something that we would
need to look at
um so
yeah okay
thank you my understanding was this is
to review the value for money
um that it's it's uh balancing of the
two issues that are of the cost at first
what you get so that was my
understanding and but I just just
noticing I mean we've moved on from the
things as task and finishes to items to
be scheduled but I just see now we're
discussing this being a test included no
I'm just wondering in terms of criteria
how are we should things initially just
come to an agenda item and then we go to
a task and finish if we feel no uh
and a job of work to be done that we can
you know restrictively contribute to or
or you know it's a reason why this one
maybe might be initially those capacity
of these questions
okay
oh we decided
um
some things are better to be done for
the tasky finished field I'm not saying
that this year but I'm just saying
possible and put you know is there a
different name
it could have a lot more flexibility to
to to look at things
and it's easier to sort of think back
talk about getting so on and rather than
a big committed at me at me
looks basically
I mean if I may I I realize that we make
that decision my question was process
one about what criteria we have and how
we make that decision you know we've
already said that the airport example is
very hard to make decisions when you've
got a one sentence overview so I suppose
I'm trying to open this question about
how do we decide if something is
potassium finish and whether it's worth
maybe mostly having things as agenda
items but I'm new to scrutiny so I'm
very much listening to The Experts both
officers and Veterans well I didn't know
anything about
foreign
yeah I think yeah just to answer the
question Alex rather give us portfolio
is a tasks can finish here I think it's
just some items like this are quite
large and complex and you want to really
get into it it's probably just seen as
more suited to be a task Advantage group
rather than likely would put uh to come
into a debate for a couple of hours you
might want to do a couple of other
things on the agenda that night so a
task Infinity script would be just a
dedicated one two three or four five
meetings
um however many of you choose to have I
think that was just the idea of somebody
to just look on the outset of looking
like a task and finish item but again it
didn't happen
there's also the option of doing them
you can do short fantastic and finished
group pieces of work as well just focus
on like a single day where you like if
you think it's
quite small item doesn't need a long
attractive thing but you need more than
just an item on an agenda and you can
just do it on a single day get all the
offices and people who you need to hear
from and just do it in one day and then
a quick report out
I'll kill them
okay so just seeing having more
information so we're going to put
because whether it's sat with the school
to me in a way at this stage
[Music]
please
people here
foreign